an aquatic Bromance horrors of the deep
and an AI daddy the long-awaited trailer
for Aquaman and the lost kingdom is
packed with details that might have swum
right past you
not only is Aquaman back for Aquaman and
the lost kingdom but the DC sequel
expands the fish-friendly hero's
wardrobe putting a spin on the Classic
Blue stealth suit from the comics the
blue suit debuted in 1986 as Aquaman
number one and its ability to allow
Aquaman to blend in while underwater
proved to be a contrast to his iconic
orange and green outfit as with all
superhero costume changes the blue
camouflage suit has its fans and
detractors however it's hard not to
appreciate a nod to a deep piece of DC
Comics lore it seems that Jason Momoa
and James Wan are fans of the blue
camouflage suits as the Aquaman and the
Lost Kingdom trailer gives a great look
at the hero's new costume in the trailer
we see Aquaman Donnie in his new dark
blue suit using its camouflage
technology which seemingly makes him
invisible to break into the desert
prison housing orb although it probably
won't be around for long simply
referencing Aquaman's comic book
wardrobe change will surely be enough to
satisfy Die Hard fans and it's always
possible he's wearing the suits and
other scenes in the trailer you just
can't see him
at long last Aquaman and the lost
kingdom sees the return of DC's favorite
couple well maybe not exactly for those
wondering Amber Heard is definitely
reprising her role as the queen of
Atlantis for highly publicized
defamation trial involving ex-husband
Johnny Depp caused the backlash with
fans even calling for her replacement
but lo and behold she's in at least one
shot of the new trailer the majority of
the footage shows Arthur's relationship
with his reluctant half-brother orm as
they team up to save Atlantis from Black
Manta brother high five do not call me
brother
so where does that leave Mara it's hard
to say in a succession of increasingly
fast-paced action shots Mira appears in
only one brief moment where she seems to
be trying to break through a window
underwater even when Arthur appears
happy with his baby Mara is hardly in
the picture James Wan has admitted to
Entertainment Weekly that the film
doesn't focus on Arthur's romantic
entanglements but instead on the two
brothers with a scaled down role in the
movie story it makes sense then why she
doesn't appear prominently in the
trailer by skipping ahead four years
viewers will have missed out on a lot of
the development between Arthur and Mara
but hopefully we at least get to see her
be with her family
one of the most appealing aspects of the
world of Aquaman is that there's no
shortage of odd creatures and humanoid
hybrids that can come into play when
Arthur Curry is in Atlantis the trailer
for Aquaman and the lost kingdom offers
a glimpse of plenty of new additions
including some hammerhead shark people
flanking Arthur and orm while they're
underwater these could very well be some
Associates of king shark who entered the
DC EU in The Suicide Squad
your friends
but according to some reports the movie
is set to feature the character of
Carson another shark from DC Comics who
rapidly evolved to human-like
intelligence and telepathy after being
hit with a dose of radiation so even
though they look similar we wouldn't
count on king shark showing up he might
be too weird even for an Aquaman movie
the Aquaman and the Lost Kingdom trailer
holds plenty of references to the
Aquatic superheroes past but one of its
more veiled references may actually be a
nod to the real-life history of his
actor four years ago I was basically
unemployed
Wanderer with no home this line about
the hero's history actually mirrors that
of Jason Momoa who has revealed in
interviews that he struggled with a
prolonged period of unemployment after
his breakout stint is called Drogo on
Game of Thrones he once told in style I
couldn't get work it's very challenging
when you have babies and you're
completely in debt I mean what are you
gonna put Drogo in a comedy it's like
where the hell do you put him a bit
later in the trailer Aquaman declares
that he finally got a job as a king of
Atlantis in a similar vein Mamoa has
struggled to find work improved when he
was cast as Aquaman in the DC EU momoa's
final appearance on Game of Thrones was
in 2012 while this debut as Aquaman came
in 2016 four-year Gap is this an
intentional to reference the Momoa story
maybe not but it's hard to ignore the
parallels
at least one thing is clear from the
Aquaman and the Lost Kingdom trailer
director James Wan is letting his horror
Roots show more than ever while the
first Aquaman movie had some scary
sequences of its own the horror dial is
clearly getting cranked up to 11 for the
sequel as viewers can see where
ostensibly zombified atlanteans rising
up to do battle with Atlantis while
casual fans may not have picked up on as
that one appears to finally begin in an
opportunity to make the four tinged
Atlanta story that he has long desired
at one point in time the esteemed horror
director was slated to direct an Aquaman
spin-off called the trench which would
focus on the Sinister beings that
Aquaman faces off against in his first
movie unfortunately the project was
canned leaving eager fans worried that
once take on a more overtly
horror-inspired DC project would not
come to fruition thankfully this latest
trailer suggests that he managed to make
his wish come true albeits in a
different form it seems that Aquaman and
the lost kingdom may be drawing more
from wands scrapped the trench movie
than some may have expected the director
once revealed that the canceled film was
stealthily going to feature Black Manta
whose gruesome story is now front and
center he's also teased at the the
Aquaman sequel will bring back other
Concepts from the trench speaking
comicbook.com Juan said listen I feel
like everything I come up with
everything I do if I come up with
something that I don't end up using that
doesn't mean that I cannot be inspired
to use that in a different way
perhaps one of the most interesting
details in the Aquaman and the Lost
Kingdom trailer happens as the first
look wraps up pay close attention to the
final moments as the credits for the
film come up and viewers will see that
Jason Momoa has received a story by
credit alongside James Wan David Leslie
Johnson McGoldrick and Thomas possibit
while Momoa didn't write the script the
lost kingdom does feature story ideas
from the actor during an interview with
The Hollywood Reporter in 2022 Mamoa
expressed just how excited he was to
have played a part in the sequel's
narrative revealing that he wrote a
50-page treatment for the project
teasing the sequel the actor said it's
got my heart in it out of the writing
process start in an interview with Drew
Barrymore Momoa candidly discussed what
it was like to cook up the sequel
revealing that he worked on the first
treatment and Juan and Johnson
McGoldrick finished it off after we
ended the first one I went in with my
writing partner and we you know I kind
of dreamed up the second one Black Manta
is more powerful than ever and Aquaman
in the lost kingdom thanks to his
acquisition of the black Trident however
that may not be the only upgrade he gets
in a sequel and maybe a bit of a stretch
but around the 52 second Mark of the
trailer it gets inside a vessel that
could be a loose adaptation of the mecca
Manta from the comics I'm gonna kill
Aquaman and destroy everything he holds
dear the mechamanta is a fairly new
addition to Black manta's Arsenal in the
comics coming into play originally an
Aquaman Volume 8 number 51 which came
out in 2019. it's an artificial
intelligence gifted to the super villain
by Lex Luthor that emulates the thoughts
of black manta's deceased father and
also doesn't hurt that it's encased in a
giant robot capable of destroying its
opponents granted it's hard to tell from
the trailer whether it is in fact an
adaptation of the mechamanta it could
just be another random vessel Black
Manta uses to wage his war against sea
dwellers it's worth noting that
audiences saw black manta's father die
in the first Aquaman movie
given how the sequel seems to emphasize
the importance of family it wouldn't be
out of the question for a dear old dad
to come back into the mix and again
there's likely already so much going on
in the sequel that adding an AI layer
could make things even more convoluted
the trailer for Aquaman and the lost
kingdom is filled to the brim with
narrative threads that are worth
unraveling while Arthur Curry is
definitely struggling with being a
father in The Cinematic outing he's also
dealing with being a good brother at the
end of the first Aquaman Curry's
half-brother orm is imprisoned after his
Gambit to take over Atlantis flops or
Curry and Orem were never on the best of
terms the final moments of Aquaman
cemented the animosity the two had for
one another in the lost kingdom ormus
surprisingly back and the VIP shares
with curry is nothing short of hilarious
the trailer shows Curry having no choice
but to break orm out of prison so they
can stop Black Manta together making the
sequel a true Family Affair from there
the trailer makes it a point to hammer
home how warm and Aquaman are on this
strange journey together whether they
like it or not needless to say the
Bromance Vibes are oozing thanks to the
chemistry between Wilson and Momoa while
speaking with Entertainment Weekly
director James Wan candidly discussed
how he always wanted Aquaman 2 to focus
on the two estranged Brothers he
revealed the second movie was always
going to be Arthur and orm so the first
was a romance action adventure movie the
second one is a bromance action
adventure movie
foreign